BUT SADLY, OUR OBSESSION
WITH CLOTHING OFTEN MEANS
THAT PEOPLE WILL GO
AS FAR AS STEALING
JUST TO GET THEIR HANDS
ON THAT HOT NEW STYLE.
AND NO ONE KNOWS THIS BETTER
THAN GABRIELLE ROMERO,
MANAGER OF HARDWEAR CLOTHING
IN LARCHMONT VILLAGE,
CALIFORNIA.
- OFTENTIMES WHEN SHOPLIFTING,
THEY COME IN TEAMS,
USUALLY MORE THAN ONE PERSON,
USUALLY ABOUT THREE PEOPLE.
- IT'S THE REAL DARK SIDE
OF RUNNING A CLOTHING STORE,
BUT OFTEN IN BUSINESS,
A NEGATIVE LIKE THIS
CAN ACTUALLY BE TURNED
INTO A POSITIVE.
AND THAT'S WHY I'M HERE.
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE TRICKS
PEOPLE DO
TO STEAL STUFF?
- UM, DEFINITELY, THEY C--
THEY TRAVEL IN PACKS.
- SORRY, YOU WERE LOOKING
AT MY HAT.
- OH, IT'S OKAY.
- OH, OKAY. IS IT--
IS IT OK--
IS IT WEIRD, OR--
- NO. YOUR HAT?
- I DON'T NORMALLY WEAR...
- NO, IT LOOKS GOOD.
- THIS TYPE OF HAT.
- I LIKE IT.
- OH, IT'S OKAY.
I DON'T HAVE TO WEAR IT.
- OKAY.
- ALL RIGHT.
- BETTER?
- SORRY, YEAH.
SO WHAT WERE YOU SAYING
ABOUT SHOPLIFTING?
- I DON'T REMEMBER.
IT HAPPENS.
- BUT MAYBE SHOPLIFTING
ISN'T SUCH A BAD THING.
YOU SEE, IN FASHION,
GOOD-LOOKING PEOPLE
ARE TRENDSETTERS.
SO RATHER THAN TRYING TO STOP
ALL SHOPLIFTERS,
HARDWEAR CAN BENEFIT
BY LETTING ATTRACTIVE THIEVES
GO FREE,
BECAUSE IF ATTRACTIVE PEOPLE
WEAR IT,
THEIR LESS ATTRACTIVE FRIENDS
WILL COME AND BUY IT.
- OH.
OKAY.
- WHAT--WHAT DO YOU THINK?
- SO WE JUST WAIT
FOR AN ATTRACTIVE PERSON
TO COME IN?
DO I HAVE TO THINK
THEY'RE ATTRACTIVE?
WHO'S THE JUDGE?
- WELL, THAT'S WHAT WE
HAVE TO DECIDE.
EACH COME UP WITH A LIST
OF TRAITS
THAT THEY FIND ATTRACTIVE.
THEN LATER,
I COMPILED ALL THE TRAITS
INTO A MASTER LIST.
NOW I NEEDED SOMEONE
TO ENFORCE IT,
SO I HIRED
A SECURITY GUARD.
SIMON?
- HI, GOOD TO MEET YOU.
- THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING OUT.
- OKAY.
- SO WE'RE DOING
THIS THING HERE
WHERE WE'RE ALLOWING PEOPLE
TO SHOPLIFT ONE ITEM,
BUT ONLY
IF THEY'RE ATTRACTIVE.
- OKAY.
- SO THE STAFF AND I
CAME UP WITH A LIST
OF, UH, SOME TRAITS
THAT QUALIFY A PERSON
AS ATTRACTIVE.
- RIGHT.
- SO, BASICALLY,
IF SOMEONE MEETS
ALL THESE TRAITS,
YOU KNOW,
THEY'RE ALLOWED TO SHOPLIFT.
OTHERWISE,
YOU HAVE TO STOP THEM.
- OKAY.
YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY,
THINGS LIKE "BIG PENIS"
JUST APPLY TO MEN.
- RIGHT.
- WITH EVERYTHING IN PLACE,
WE WERE READY TO OPEN OUR DOORS
TO CUSTOMERS.
[upbeat techno music]
♪
THE NORMAL TRAFFIC
WAS COMING IN,
BUT I REALIZED THAT PEOPLE
WERE MISSING THE SIGN OUT FRONT.
SO JUST TO BE SAFE,
I WENT UP TO EACH PERSON
AND TOLD THEM
ABOUT THE PROMOTION.
WE'RE DOING
A SPECIAL PROMOTION TODAY
WHERE ATTRACTIVE PEOPLE ARE
ALLOWED TO STEAL ONE ITEM.
TO SHOPLIFT ONE ITEM.
- YOU WORK HERE?
- I'M REPRESENTING
THE BUSINESS.
- WHY WOULD YOU TELL ME
TO STEAL SOMETHING?
- IT'S A SPECIAL PROMOTION.
- OKAY.
- IT WAS WORKING GREAT,
AS SEVERAL WOMEN
WERE SHOPLIFTING ITEMS.
- BUT ACCORDING TO SIMON,
THE FIRST FEW WOMEN
JUST DIDN'T MAKE THE CUT.
- SHE DIDN'T PAY
FOR THE ITEM.
- IT WAS STRANGE BECAUSE THESE
WOMEN WERE ATTRACTIVE,
BUT THEN I BEGAN TO SUSPECT
THAT OUR SECURITY GUARD
ONLY CARED
ABOUT ONE THING.
- HAVE A GOOD DAY.
- THANK YOU, YOU TOO.
- WHAT DID YOU THINK
OF HER?
- SHE WAS, UH,
SHE WAS RATHER PRETTY.
- WHAT DID YOU LIKE
ABOUT HER THE MOST?
- UH, HER FIGURE.
SHE HAD, YOU KNOW,
A PRETTY--PRETTY GOOD BUILD.
- OH. DO YOU LIKE THAT?
- YES.
- WAIT, WHAT DO YOU LIKE?
- UM, YOU KNOW,
THE WAY HER--
THE WAY HER B--
HER CHEST WAS.
- IS THAT WHAT YOU
WERE LOOKING AT THE MOST?
- UM, YEAH.
AND ALSO SHE WAS--
HER F--HER FACE
WAS SORT OF PRETTY,
BUT, YOU KNOW, NOT--
NOT, LIKE, TOTALLY PRETTY.
- THE PART YOU LIKED WAS--
- YEAH.
IT WAS--
- BIG BOOBS
WASN'T ON THE LIST.
AND CLEARLY, SIMON HAD
AN OBSESSION.
AND AFTER STOPPING
SEVERAL MORE ATTRACTIVE WOMEN
WITH MODEST CHESTS...
- YOU HAVE TO--YOU HAVE TO PAY
FOR ALL YOUR ITEMS.
- OKAY.
- I HAD TO INTERVENE.
LET'S SAY THERE'S NO LIST.
YOU JUST SEE HER ON THE STREET.
WHAT DO YOU--
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF HER?
- SHE IS SOMEWHAT PRETTY,
BUT SHE COULD BE PRETTIER.
- AND WHAT WOULD MAKE HER
PRETTIER?
- UH, TO LET HER HAIR DOWN
AND, YOU KNOW...
MAYBE SMI--
- AND WHAT WAS THAT?
YOU DID THAT AFTER.
TO LET HER HAIR DOWN AND WHAT?
"AND, YOU KNOW--"
I HAD TO TAKE SIMON ASIDE.
SO YOU'RE SAYING
DOUBLE "D" BREASTS
ARE ESSENTIAL FOR YOU?
- IT'S GOTTA BE--
IT'S GOTTA BE SUBSTANTIAL.
- ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT, WELL,
STICK TO THE LIST THEN, FOR NOW.
- ALL RIGHT,
I'LL STICK TO THE LIST.